my name is Hillary O'Neal and I am a
professional ski Mountaineer and
adventurer today we're going to talk
about ultralight camping the ethos
behind ultralight camping is having the
most minimal setup you need in order to
complete whatever objective it is you're
setting out for so let's say you're
trying to connect multiple 14 hours in
Colorado and you plan to be out for two
nights you really have to look at what
it is you need versus what it is you
want there are certain types of
equipment that I have come to love when
I need to shave ounces one of those that
I think of offhand would be certain
kinds of sleeping bags at our 3/4 length
and have light very simple zippers a key
facet of ultralight camping is
multifunctional equipment for example
the backpack that you can carry and then
use it as your sleeping pad at night or
the down coat that can become your
pillow put more time on the front end
and de planning and you're going to have
a better experience when you're actually
out trying to accomplish something
through ultralight camping one of the
most important aspects of ultralight
camping is picking an optimal spot for
where you're going to spend your night
be sure you find a place that provides
shelter from wind from weather put a lot
of thought into that factor because you
just don't have a lot of margin for
error by using these three aspects of
ultralight camping you will be able to
go out and accomplish bigger objectives
in a lighter faster way
[Music]
you
[Music]
you